ken felix ghosts
are real no are you a believer
no they're not real don't tell me the
real i'm about to change your mind right
now because we have hard
evidence hard evidence of ghosts caught
in camera
oh my god okay for real you don't
believe in ghosts right
no but i do get it does get in my head
and i get like that fight or flight
feeling oh really i want to go stuff
yeah
after i watch it like the next day i'm
like what if
like looking around are you
superstitious at all like if you want
something to do well that's out of your
control do you do something
no no i don't i mean you know yeah i'm
not
any of this too many horror games have
ruined me they ruined you
i remember telling marcie the other day
i'm like i never get scared anymore
she's like
but she got terrified last night because
there was a noise
but the thing is if i'm sleeping and i
hear a noise i think someone's breaking
in and i'm like
look get the bat yeah
it's not a ah it's a oh who are you
what are you gonna do it yeah you got to
get man mood you're gonna yeah you gotta
fight them all
oh man what do you what do you use to
defend yourself if somebody breaks in
there
oh we're we're legally not allowed to
have anything
my sister came home really late and my
dad brought a tennis bracket
and he went hey what are you doing there
and my sister was just like that it's me
what do you do
[Laughter]
you about served her up bro yeah
like give a bunch of like like waffles
smacks with a
tennis racket oh there's too many
tangents we gotta watch the video
here we go
[Music]
three videos capturing on camera three
there's four videos you dumbass with
that
learn to count have you seen this
they've got no i haven't
talked this will blow your mind some of
the most
unsettling images on the web that
the raffles hotel in singapore four
security cameras survey the area around
the elevator
i don't know where to look at this
there's some guys walking they go to the
elevator
okay in the bottom right for a second a
light appears
it's past midnight whoa
whoa a light appears oh my gosh dude
goes thrill now
ghost reel now you don't think it was
like they pushed the elevator button so
the elevator started moving and there's
like a little crack or some light
showing through no
no don't
i mean oh my god
oh my god we need to do this like shane
dawson used to do like
oh my god oh my god what would he always
say
oh my god did you see that oh oh it was
right there on the wall
on the elevator oh oh my god i'm so
startled
another one again again oh it almost
this is the perfect pace
oh man
if they just died i would be like whoa
okay
if they just killed over like okay all
right
all right now i'm listening i'm always
trying to think like what would convince
me right
yeah because everyone has a ghost story
do i have a ghost story let me think
oh it's not actually a ghost story i
have a story where i had like a night
terror before yeah scares the crap out
of me
same that's the only thing i have too i
was laying in my bed
and i turned over and i swear to god
there was like someone's like face there
and i blinked and it didn't go away and
so
then i was like whoa i jumped on the
other side of the bed and i was like
jesus christ
what the what was that i love that i got
me goosebumps
hell yeah okay that scared me so
freaking bad
it didn't go away i was like okay that's
right my eyes are like doing the thing
but it
have you ever done the thing okay this
wait wait i gotta ask more questions
about that
okay do you think it was like your mom
or something and you were just half
awake
no no there was no there was nobody
there like because it was your
wait let me tell you mine first okay
okay okay so i had that very similar but
i was like
five or six years old right and i was
sleeping uh
and the same thing happened where i look
out in the room and on the other side of
the room
that we have a bookshelf and i could see
a skeleton like
fiddle with a bookshelf and then it
would see me
and then he would walk up to me and it
would grab my head with his hands and i
was so freaked out by it and then it
would just like stare at me
it was terrifying
and for the longest time i'm like well i
mean ghosts are real i saw it
it took me way too long to realize what
a night tarot was
because that's clearly what happened so
the thing i was going to ask have you
ever did a thing to where you're like
laying you're laying in bed you know
marty's beside you
and you turn and look at her and like
her face looks scary
how dare you insinuate that the most
beautiful woman in the world
looks scary is that what you think
american
well this happened one time
i was like oh i was laying in bed and
like turned over
and she was she was like she was like
awake and she was like blinking at me
but the face that i saw looked like
scary
and i was like i like jumped and like
put my hand on her face
like i was like stepping around stepping
on like a sports player like poop
and she's like what are you doing and i
was like oh god you look scary for a
second i'm sorry
she took a fence like
there is something freaky with the eyes
closed but marzia
is very specific that i can't look at
her when she's sleeping because i used
to do that
and i freak her out because she opens
her eyes and i'm just like
creepy monster in movies that hunch over
and stare at them sleeping
they look at you and you freak out about
it all right we gotta
we gotta watch some more footage here
okay this is some hardcore
evidence have you seen this no i haven't
seen this
okay let's watch it this is hard
evidence
all right you have kids do they do this
did this fall on the ground
well we have on the rugs they do yeah
those flop on the ground
it looks kind of creepy the way she
falls it's not gonna lie though yeah she
does fall pretty hard like
i gotta i gotta say i have some newfound
respect for ghosts
because they pushing babies down i mean
if no one
knows what you're doing would you push
your child ken
no because i would no because i wouldn't
of course not dude i'm more freaked out
about
okay hit like the less than key on your
keyboard like go back a couple of frames
you see that okay oh god i thought you
meant the baby there looks fake well
there is a baby there no it's a real
baby
baby like okay you see that white square
on the wall
like besides the pictures up there if
you like go go back and play it a little
bit
there's a face no yeah there's a face
whoa whoa what the [ __ ]
that's super creepy how do you notice
that you notice everything
[Music]
i think they're watching they got me
watching i don't know what is that jesus
let's give it a try beetle
keeps coming near my light
have you seen this get attacked by a bug
now i've never seen this
bugs are scary yeah bugs are scary
i know dude i come on all right time
stamps
it's just setting you up you know it's
getting the let it let it play for one
minute
as they investigate they start to pick
up some very bizarre k2 emf
readings oh my god dude
k2 oh my god the k2 ken oh my god
check out the upstairs and see
a couple having sex in the back
why are they so focused on this [ __ ]
bee i don't know he's really bothering
him hey get out of here
this bee keeps trying to attack us it's
cursed
[Music]
get out of here b i wish we had some
spray to kill it
what what is it what did they capture
where is it
the chair is it the chair
whoa do you see that what is it that the
ghost
the smoke is that the ghost is that it
no that can't be it you see it
a strange mister smoke-like apparition
seems to form right in front of them
that's it that's okay that's the ghost
he probably just farted come on
get out of here you can waste my time
turn a light on there's nobody up here
there's literally nothing in here uh
what are you doing
what the [ __ ] is all this jesus
and look how heavy this is what do you
mean nothing's in here
you're a treasure trove oh what's that
[ __ ] is all this
what is all that you know his wife is
like
fine you can keep all this but it has to
go put him in the attic
i don't want to see him
hear the familiar sound of shuffling
legos
and run down the hall to record they
caught something
incredibly creepy on camera okay
okay i heard
[Music]
that's that okay you only heard it for a
brief moment
did you see it no no no there's nothing
up here
a [ __ ] sign is that one of his toys
what is that
what are we looking at whoa
whoa this reminds me i have a similar
story
of aliens oh my god
it moved bruh me and myself did a video
actually talking about this
yeah when we lived back in sweden one
night martial heard a noise we both
heard a noise actually
and we live in a super small flat like
the entry was basically
our bedroom and we i didn't investigate
it
but when we woke up there was this thing
i don't know what it was it kind of
looked the shape of the half-life
monster you know with the legs and
but flatter like the head crab yeah the
head crab but
flat and like it was made out of
cardboard or something
and it was on our carpet next to our
entry
i was so freaked out by it that i was
just like well
maya brought it here uh and then i threw
it away
i threw it away right away because i was
so freaked out by it i didn't know how
it got there
i don't know how the what it was and i
will never know what it was
because i just threw it away and mars is
so mad at me for doing that because we
never got to know what it was
wow it kind of reminded me of the shape
of what they saw actually
did you see it the totally moving back
there
yeah yeah it kind of reminded me of that
but more brownish looking
maybe sane maybe ghost israel
maybe hmm i'm getting into this
yeah yeah it goes through a pair of
paranormal investigations going on here
okay so i don't know if i ever told you
this but you know a long time when we
were partnered with a certain place
they were asking me for ideas uh for
like series to do
and one of my ideas was like load us up
with some cameras
and go let us do paranormal
investigations you were ahead of the
time that's so popular
i tried to get him to do that and they
were like no that wouldn't work
and that wouldn't work people love that
[ __ ]
what i know i was like dude get all
those youtubers together doing this that
would be freaking great
that's a great idea we should have done
that what the [ __ ] yeah yeah
maybe we can one day still i don't know
if i want to but you know
yeah watching this i'm a little scared
oh is that the toy
jesus i think it's huge bionicle
seemingly turns its head
to look wait the bio it was a bionicle
that came to my house
did he say there's a lego toy that
turned to look at him yeah is that what
he said
yeah bionic chronicle bro bro come on it
was banana
it did turn it did turn you saw it turn
toy story reel everything real now
credit users speculated that the toy was
battery powered and that was why the
head moved
bleachpong posted close-up pictures of
the toy's neck
to show that there was no mechanical
mechanism at work
so his bleach pong and his family
haunted by a child goes to
just wants to play legos they could
easily have been someone behind there
right
yeah that or i have another explanation
okay
this is like a there's like a small
small room with no windows and it's
curved you know you know they open the
door quickly the airflow
yeah yeah maybe it's like wait there's
no venting
there's no ventilation in a room like
this is it that makes the
what the air move more right like it's
if there's no ventilation or anything
it's like kind of like a little sealed
thing and then you open the door
all right
okay if i got a door that's like
slightly open and i go and open another
door
that door will move right that's what
i'm saying like do you not have that in
your house but
it's the back of the room there's no is
there there has to be a
door behind here then for that to work
no i'm not saying like
the wind goes it blows past it okay so
have you do
okay in your house have you ever do you
have any door in your
in your house that like if it's a little
open and like someone opens the front
door it moves a little bit
yeah yeah same thing that's what i'm
saying same thing okay
[Music]
maybe maybe not okay no maybe not maybe
you're right who knows i'm just trying
to
i'm just trying to piece it together oh
yeah yeah yeah
all right someone's driving away
zoom in mackie come on mikey give us the
footage it's funny how every time
there's ghost footage it's always like
poorly recorded yeah it's just like back
in the day of like
ufos right bigfoot
what are we looking at
[Music]
this is just fabricated i don't like
this you know like that one
you know i want to get a real spook
the urban ghost urban exploration urban
ghost urban exploration urban urban
ghosts frank from franco tv decides that
they should try a sean
is it urban though is it an urban sands
yeah urban seance
i mean then things get a little spooky
can you come closer to me
all right i like the dude on the right
here they had to do on the right his
eyes got real big he was like
can you make a sound
don't move don't move don't move don't
move
[Music]
is that the front door draft theory you
have there again ken
yeah maybe it is got to be right the
thing with these kind of is that
you can't trust them because they are
there for content right
yeah i like the more like the yeah the
reddit set up where it's like oh
something creepy happened let's uh film
it see what happened
look look in the window look in the
window there's a head there's somebody
looking at us looking at that
come on man look at that window
are you kidding me this is so dumb
what do we do what do we do there's a
window there's a guy what a wedding
there's definitely something
[Laughter]
[Music]
here's what you do if you see a ghost
they want to creep you out right
that's their goal their ghosts they want
to freak you out right yes
you freak them out even more yes
yeah that's what i'm talking about yeah
you go bananas you're like
[Music]
like you know when you're you're in the
shower right and you got like you're
trying to wash your face you have to
close your eyes and you're having those
intrusive thoughts of like the ghost
coming in there
you're like watching your face and
you're naked you guys start like doing
like a sexy dance like come on ghost
you want some of this come on and get me
you wait time to watch it bye if you're
gonna kill me you're gonna be real
freaked out about this
and people are weird about me sitting in
the shower what the [ __ ] is this i try
to i try to just creep the ghosts out
you know
oh you want to get me well we're going
to be sexy about it and the ghost is
like
no just nah ain't cool there that
actually makes
so much sense i i 100 use this as well
we're just going to be in the bathroom
looking like what are you doing
[Music]
that's a big brain right there i've been
doing it for
exactly you made it this far i mean you
can't can't argue with that logic
it's like that pivotal moment in the
film everything's going down
it's like all right guys i know what we
need to do there's something
coming out that's the weirdest dance you
got
everybody pull your pants down start
dancing freaked out
through the helicopter then the
detective shows up why are all these
people
dead with their pants down in here
god damn we just solved ghosts ken
yeah we did it right right here right
now all right let's watch more the house
of the devil
it doesn't go well
i was praying dude i'd be praying if i
was in this house this house looks scary
man
yeah whoa
oh this guy charges against it i like
that oh this guy's
freaking brave but he's praying
[Music]
i would love if he charges after uh
whatever is doing it
and then as it goes and he's like oh
[ __ ] you're not supposed to see me
whoa dude what the [ __ ]
oh
do you think the ghost is having a laugh
the whole time look at his face
what
i've been hearing [ __ ]
he never looks at the direction of where
the door is
right i think they hear it coming from
this room it keeps charging it
yeah this is like please god
save me like runs through the room
[Laughter]
but he's looking to the left he needs to
look at the right there
[Applause]
there you go all right i can't watch
this okay
ghost caught on camera 18 million views
yeah it's got to be legitimate it's got
views yeah that's how it works
i love these because i never know where
to look okay i think i know where to lay
oh that door just opened that door here
that was pretty strong though
slammed the door i got scared yeah
it scared you yes that ghost is having a
bad day
like go back to school no i don't want
to go back to
deer park cbs 2 lockers whoa oh
okay well chill out there right by the
window too huh okay look
i know what happened here i've seen i've
seen the movies some some kid got locked
in
even though those are very small squares
he got locked in there
and he's just trying to get out nobody
let him out okay
[Music]
isn't this uh footage a bit low to be
security camera footage
yeah yeah you see they have a security
camera right here
yeah this is like it's way higher yeah
but that makes no sense
it probably won't even fall all the way
over yeah they don't actually they don't
actually do any damage you know just
shakes all right don't you jump in front
of my face don't be a jump scare
a surprise or something while we wha
oh hang on go go watch that again did
the paper come out before the thing
opened
yeah up didn't i think it fell on the
bottom
ah out of the bottom yeah yeah okay the
root goes
you're just it's going to take hours to
clean this up why are you doing this
yeah yeah come on ghost make it a mess
there it is oh my god did you see that
ken
kicked the sign over this is a wet floor
is that it yeah that's it who organized
boxes like this
with the corners there and that oh my
god there's clearly space to move this
out a little bit so you can put them oh
my god
he's got those corner lockers i feel bad
for him yeah what in the world
comments turned off like in this like
ratio turn up
yeah everybody's like nah bruh nah this
is legit
this is legit oh 420 oh
we got a baker here he's baking some
stuff up or is he doing some chemistry
i don't know i like this because it's
bright in the room
yeah yeah yeah this is from a lab whoa
oh someone knocked over the chocolate
oh man i gotta clean that up
not 4 20 anymore leave the room oh
he's like dude look it fell look at it
look at this
what are you made of mess dude don't
blame the ghosts are you kidding me
i was over there doing that and it fell
over i didn't even touch it whatever man
get out of here
come on you're over acting dude yeah
they're so
they're so animated you can't mop that
off right away you got to clean it up
first man
don't put a mop on that what is he doing
i hope this goes
kicks the mop everybody oh what the hell
oh
i didn't see it i was looking at the mob
he
moved the the bottle moved a little bit
right in front of him like a cat about
to push it off the edge
the ghost cat uh uh
oh there's even like a puff of smoke
there too nice nice nice
well i believe in ghost can now yeah
it's real it's legit
the actor went to shatner school of
overreacting yeah
what was that hell yeah well ken
i hope i convinced you that ghosts are
in fact real
no don't don't say it's over i'm too
scared to be alone right now
and remember the dark is
always darker when the lights are off
[Music]
and you can't go to the zoo need to go
to the [ __ ] loop
i got something
just download it for free for free [ __ ]
download
i got something for you
[Applause]
you